[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we have supplies this sewing Thank You
Paula into the public members of the
public sorry you try not anything now
please thank you very much well good
evening everyone rent out the other
emergency evacuation announcement so in
the event of a fire or other emergency
please exit the building in an orderly
manner to the assembly point which is
located in the market car park the fire
exit sign in this room is indicated by
green fire exit sign please do not delay
the evacuation by collecting any
belongings don't use the lift the
premises must not be reactant until the
fire brigade of give the all clear
please notice against the law to smoke
on these premises and please note that
this meeting will be audio recorded so
start on the agenda if I may good
evening everyone and very welcome to
those members of the public and other
counselors at joining us this evening
apologies for absence of apologies from
caps to June lovely he's got a point
that arise this evening non members
attending the list so it's counselor
casar counselor both give extra mrs.
Hawaii counterfeiting Council Shore cats
Reeves calcis daddy and Counsell
Williams so make sure those have been
issued
right minutes of the meeting held on the
9th or no heaven but is it your wish I
signed up as a true record very great
thank you if anything coming up in those
minutes not mentioned elsewhere in the
agenda please do come forward with them
any declarations of interest please yes
please Thank You chairman and a
non-pecuniary interesting item seven
wasn't my the Town Council Thank You
Jared same thank you did I thank you
right masses refer to the executive
reports from other committees there are
none as the interest this evening is in
item seven which is the public toilet
strategy are proposing to bring that
nice and forward first if I may so we'll
cover that item now so it's to hear from
the portfolio hold of the environment on
a strategy for public topics it makes a
please go hit Thank you Thank You
chairman just for the benefit of our
visitors this evening who may not be
quite as familiar with the council
procedures when we had our way day in
November where we have a bit of a
barnstorming brainstorming session
regarding future budgetary issues we
highlighted by Officer myself the
situational is developed in in our
portfolio that the options to meet our
saving requirements is becoming
extremely restricted and that the issue
of maintaining public toilets which is a
non statutory requirement becomes very
high on our agenda of potential cuts now
this is not the first time this issue
has been raised chairman it was raised
in 2011 in 2014 here we are in 2016
having the same conversation I'm pretty
sure this issue is not going to go away
if we can miraculously find some money
from somewhere to make it go away this
year we're going to be having the same
conversation next year but as far as we
can see in our portfolio we have no
funding available to
of potential gap other than with this
issue this is why we highlighted this at
the away though chairman and asked for a
certain amount of authority myself and
the i-beam mr. Hoffman to see if we
could come up with a longer-term
solution so that this issue is resolved
the security of the toilet is put in
place and we don't have to keep going
down this very sensitive road taking
this on board we looked at a number of
issues that potentially could have
helped the situation working with third
parties and in the end while if there
was community toward it's gotta be
discussed in the report you can see
chairman that we looked at it but there
are a number of aerial variables that
make what potentially could be savings
if you have agreements with people they
could disappear the company closes they
move away it became well what we were
looking for was to to make a situation
that neither mr. huntin or myself want
to actually enforce which is to close
the toilets but being forced into that
position is not something we want to go
down but that he's very much on the
cards if we can't come up with an
alternative we felt that the best route
was to work as a third party with our
long and trusted colleagues being the
town parish councils and in this respect
we approached the five town parish
councils that are involved with the
toilets we felt having been a town
council both when these recommendations
were made in 2011 and 2014 that we made
the same proposal Venice was made in
those times we get the same result which
was no there was no interest so what we
proposed and i would add at this stage
chairman there has been no financial
commitment made by the council in this
respect other than my time and mr. hot
ins time and most of his time has
actually been out outside office hours
in his own time so the week
go and talk to the parish town councils
involved with an outline of what we hope
to bring to full council ultimately as a
working document of working idea but if
they were in agreement we could try and
progress the idea involved chairman a
leasing agreement for ten years and that
the facilities would be replaced by new
new toilets modern up-to-date toilets
and that the operation would be the
responsibility of the various parish or
town councils we worked with one company
again no financial commitment was
involved or made and we use them because
they have the facilities in Southend and
in li the life expectancy of these new
toilets is 20 years we went to see the
ones in Southend by the curs all that
have been institute for 10 years and
they look like they were put in last
week in principle chairman we we have
floated this idea that we would install
the new toilets against a capital
expenditure we've run the potential
savings across with the financial boys
loosing comfortable that the whole
situation stacks up how the various
parish councils whether they have
charging whether they involve some sort
of spaceship will be entirely down to
them it's their operation on a day to
day basis rayleigh Rochford and
hullbridge were in principle on board
with the situation subject obviously to
what is progressed and what is aggrieved
by full council because we weren't in a
position to make any commitments
Horace's or anything else and on the
same basis the various parish councils
said the same thing yes in principle but
you know until we actually see what's on
the table they can't commit hotly hair
at the time have said that they didn't
feel that it was a justifiable
expenditure
on public finances I believe that they
may be looking for further information
subsequently to when this notice went
out Wakering i believe is almost a
non-starter chairman because the amount
of views is so minimal it has to be I
can't see how that one could be
justifiable so really jelling this is a
proposal that we'd like to progress to
full council with your superior in
agreement so that we have a further
basis that we can go and progress this
potential idea in the hope that we can
come up with a long-term solution to the
issues of the public toilet but always
bearing in mind that if we can't come to
some solution with third parties then
closure is always on the on the agenda I
don't know mr. Haughton wishes to
anything chairman well I think I'm
having one actually thank you Oh mainly
subsided is if we continue as we are I
think it's probably not financially
sustainable so that's the things that's
over group something's got to change in
how we provide that's our division if
you wish so it is there are as that's
very will be pointed out and need to
address the sum of the budget books sort
of balance the books and this is one way
forward so many ways we have that issue
to find some savings but also the
toilets themselves are for being like
it's none of them
standard and will only become a porous
landed over time so something needs to
be done to address that I think this was
their preferred option to learn with
partners sort of parish and town
councils or may fail we have all five we
discuss were very receptive and very
sympathetic to two outs with a financial
plight if you wish and their fault felt
if they could help what they could
justify putting in resources they would
do so so I think at the center today
they say three had an expression of
interest and possibly I think laughs
these I don't think we will revisit the
other two as well to see what's of
interest is I think that it wasn't an
absolutely no it was we'd like to some
more times continue its comes to this a
quitter there eventually something has
to be made I think I sense it's a rock
section 151 CMS already but you know
there is an imperative to forward plan
some of these savings now we need to do
so to give certainty there has to be
some in don't to this is going to be the
sighting by this don't so we know
closure is very much the last thing we
want to consider nothing ultimately if
no other solution can be found by that
date then that would have to be
something that was considered but you
know it's nothing to take lightly again
the caveat is an air of course about
public consultation and that's a very
important aspects of this so if we feel
that the Galatians with the parish and
town councils are not successful then
probably consultation would start for
that toilet facility handle that's not
as a question of we're going to close
you do you want to go so I would be then
looking possibly the other solutions and
options as well but they are not a
preferred option so it may get rid of a
community toilets again at that stage
but let's be clear really that the idea
would be preferred option which is a
move on to the third party where we can
live a new toilet block that's the
announcer we have better toilets and
when we sail reduced expenditure okay
can I just clarify what we're talking
about here is in many cases much better
facilities that we provide a press
yes and a consider amount of capital
investment which in the long term will
actually save us some of the revenue
costs that we have on an annual basis
yes so you know if it all comes off if
you like hopefully we will get pretty
much what we we have in front of us here
maybe even better with what you say
about further interesting in what's
going on then of course you know we may
end up entirely with something that's
all together it's absolutely not a
technical matter because the length of
Link's attend your links and always
viewed as a disposable back of the asset
then it's not something that that I
haven't been my authority to to
negotiate because it has to reach almost
go to full council say look it's a
technicality but I can't almost come up
with a done and dusted deal so they go
we've actually had the negotiations
we're fairly confident we've lost
prostitutes dot the i's and go away you
know the authority to negotiate this is
not within my remit to the London so
that that's why I'm a public debate this
time one other point if I may I think
most talent parish councillors have to
have the preset set by January so the
early negotiations I think a paramount
absolutely thanks lo que soy sauce of
man's got arms looking yes please yeah
as council sparing said this is
something that's been knocking around
for a few years on and on and off and I
think one of the strengths of the
current administration is that we're not
afraid to talk about the uncomfortable
things are not always what people want
here but we're not afraid to have the
conversations and what we're doing now
is being very transparent and open
things that we've been accused of not
being in the past so the early ideas are
being thrown out there and this early
stage report is here and there's a
there's an awful long way to go I think
it's just a tiny little bit
uncomfortable unfortunate that the first
sentence of the report talks about
closure of toilets perhaps if paragraphs
were ordered the other way around it
be clearer that the very last thing that
we're talking about here is potential
closure the term mention was also made
of needing to balance the books I think
whether we needed to balance the books
or not now is an appropriate time
because if you take the cost of the
maintenance of the toilets and based on
the survey work you look at the
annualized number of visits you get some
very interesting figures and it sounds a
bit flippant but I don't mean to be but
great wakering three pounds 28 / p
southend row 1 pound 16 / p whole bridge
1 pound 2 / be back leg 79 Pence barfi
greatly 15 pence per be now when you
start to talk about figures like that
it's clear that something needs to be
done so that the bottom of the report
some of the photographs demonstrate the
toilets are not best quality at the
moment if we're investing and that's
what we're talking about potentially
investing of resources for our residents
then quality is important and what
what's been provided at this moment
isn't necessarily best quality and if we
can come to arrangements with parish and
town councils where local much more
local councillors are able to deal with
the particular needs of their specific
environment whether it be rayleigh
hopefully where wherever i think that is
a positive way forward but as the report
clearly said known as council asparagus
clearly said this is about us in the
very early stages of a long
investigation and no decisions been made
at this point but it's absolutely right
that we're doing it now yeah yes
chairman if I might come back because
two points I might have missed I
mentioned that we've worked with one
company that supplies these toilets all
obviously if we could go down the road
of developing this situation there would
be the full procurement process to go
through so in fit in fear in theory
there could be better savings better
costings them than we currently shown
and the other aspect that we felt
working with third-parties I town and
parish council how they administer the
day-to-day operation how they get
funding they are far more likely to get
local support from businesses or
whatever then we could the reality we
know that you know being a rayleigh town
councillor I think quite often get
support for things in the raid council
are doing I can't necessarily get that
for the district until this is another
aspect but why we should be working with
the local partners and locally thank you
I don't with the with regards to the
lease side of things I know ray lee has
10 council has been very concerned about
the length of time the toilets are open
I particular gave you with the nighttime
community and the game of saying is
luxury to extend that them their clothes
quite early the name for other reasons
we all the parishes will we restrict
parishes on their ugly times or will
they be able to deal with that in their
own right with these new toilets
virtually everything is dictator ball by
whoever operates them you have opening
facilities you have lighting you have
water flow even you have whether you
charge whether what time a lot what time
they don't lock I'm a more technical
note where you won't want to hear this
sort of thing like they have facilities
for needles which okay we protect don't
want to think that this happens but it
does it's a reality of life it's all
very secure the whole unit it's almost
like Legoland you bring these units him
especially build if we found in time gun
buyers time to come that a a town
council parish council wanted to
increase the size then let's discuss it
was not as as though he's a brick
building you can module be a modular you
can literally bumped it on some speed in
pleasing thank you very much Jim yeah I
I mean I absolutely concur with what
both gasp whispering and councillor
Smith has said but just in addition the
observation is that you know these
toilets I know the radium and
specifically i think that was built in
eighteen thirty something 9339 sorry
1935 sorry there are nineteen thirties
and you know is gradually degrading and
and the problem is is that you know in
continuing to go on your respective of
might notes there's going to be fabric
maintenance I brickwork tiling
everything that goes on that's going to
be cost upon hospital costs and I think
we really do have to look very much
forward we have to look for teasingly
into the future and I think the concept
of looking ten years ahead with the
possibility that has been said that
these have got a 20-year life on them
means that there is a tremendous sense
of security with regard to the toilets
where we're virtually guaranteeing to an
extent if one can say that those toilets
for the next 20 years and personally I
think that's a
great benefit to the community I would
never really want to see us lose those
toilets I think a part of civilization
hearing in mind they are non-statutory
which I don't think a lot of people
understand and we have to look at our
budgets and how they go forward and
unfortunately this is becoming a huge
strain and we have other concerns that
we're having to look magazine which are
also causing a great strain on our
budget so overall i would i would
recommend this going forward okay thank
you are there any other speakers please
right so this is a decision being
recommended to full council just to
emphasize that so for council will be
debating these recommendations and
without any alteration one that all
public toilets with the exceptions of
properly woods are disposed / closer and
sale or through transfer of the asset
upon a long-term lease to the relevant
town Parish Council that is both of
these assets to be completed by April
2018 to the authority be delegated out
an assistant director environmental
service in consultation with the
portfolio holder for the environment and
the portfolio holder for enterprise to
oversee the closure and sale of public
toilets us but as about one subject to
the appropriate public consultation the
authority be diluted is it three that
all thought to be delegated to the
assistant director environment services
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for an environment and the
portfolio holder for enterprise to
negotiate suitable lease arrangements
with the relevant town or parish
councils and for that sugar negotiations
in three above have been successful the
investment board be asked to present a
business case in line with the budget
from principles set out in the appended
options document for the installation of
replacement public toilets on members
are in agreement really thank you very
much indeed right next item then
yeah I mean you're very welcome to stay
over to the puppy it's entirely up to
you right so I got back to item 6 this
is progress on these years I'll go page
by page if I may and please do come back
to any page if you wish to sew a page
6.1 6.2 6.3 6.4 6.5 6.6 6.7 6.8 pleased
to see that's coming forward now if you
have taken a long time 6.9 again pleased
to see that work is coming over for what
I think there was an item in the paper
today about them yeah well you know
about public consultations we're going
for here right 16
so
[Music]
yes
hmm